[Musique]
le reste à vous rappeler que c'est
aujourd'hui qu'avait lieu les obsèques
de romy schneider décédée pendant le
week-end patrick bobet y assistaient
[Musique]
voici sans avoir un petit village près
de neauphle-le-château dans les yvelines
romy schneider il y avait acheté il y à
un mois une maison avec l'intention de
s'y retirer
[Musique]
10h ce matin les amis de la comédienne
arrive peu à peu il y à michel piccoli
pierre granier-deferre genre sport
jean-claude brialy et bien d'autres au
total une cinquantaine d'un team un
petit service d'ordre contenant la
centaine de photographes et de
journalistes
la cérémonie a débuté à 10h15 dans
l'église saint-sébastien cérémonie
réduite à une simple prière prononcée
par l'abbé jean vaucanson qui s'occupe
de la paroisse
[Musique]
pendant que quelques cents curieux et
admirateurs attendaient devant le parvis
le corps de l'actrice une demi-heure
plus tard et transportés dans la tombe
du petit cimetière qui ceinturent
l'église
[Musique]
11h la brève mais émouvante cérémonie
touche à sa fin les amis les intimes les
curieux et les admirateurs qui pts le
petit village triste sous le chaud
soleil de cet été précoce triste d'avoir
perdu plus qu'une amie voilà dernier
hommage de ses amis à romy schneider
[Musique]